hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play cloudberry
Kingdom okay if you like Super Meat Boy
and any of the other side scrolling
platformers this game might be for you
because it is another chapter in the
realm of extremely challenging side
scrolling games that are gonna make me
pull my hair out and try to kill
somebody so as you can see I played it a
little bit not much but just enough to
get a feel for it and I'm going into
arcade mode there is a story mode but
the story mode progresses slowly so I'm
gonna jump right into it with the arcade
mode which has a unique feature the game
changes to your skill level meaning that
the better you play the harder it gets
so I'm gonna try to play as best I can
here and I don't know if it's what the
hell you got to collect in arcade mode
you got to collect gems to increase your
score which is totally cool and all that
and I just got a perfect one I've never
actually seen those before so I'm
assuming that there's a lot of things in
this game that I have not seen before
and you may notice some elements from
different other types of games are there
different styles of a character that you
can play is different power-ups and
doodads and whatnot and you just got to
try to be patient and plan out your
course as much as possible shut up you
doofuses with your drink ah ah ah don't
you talk back to me boy come on but this
isn't Mario it can't bash it with my
head actually did you know Mario doesn't
know hahaha
ah I was trying not to die so that it
would get harder and harder not say this
is easy right here no no don't fall cuz
I know most of all ah God I'm not gonna
get perfect score this time at least I'm
not gonna die okay as you can see
there's a little counter in the bottom
right over there I don't know if that's
like the adaptive ability and that shows
that it gets harder but I have no idea
I'm just gonna try to play as best I can
and it's not hard right now but if you
go out and see like the trailer for this
game it's pretty ridore oh ah ha was
trying to avoid that spike there I'm an
idiot I'm sorry about that I'm
performing so poorly
well there we go all right there we go
now there we go perfect you see the
little multiplier in the bottom just
went up two times two I don't know if
that multiplies my points and increases
difficulty or what I would like to think
that it does but it may or may not
alright I'm up to multiply by three I'm
trying to get some by ten which means
that I gotta get perfect scores on all
of this and by the way I went out for
this particular game to try to find to
try to play the blob OH
no no my multiplier no my markiplier
it's gone oh that was so stupid I was
right there I choked ah God so I'm
trying to talk and not concentrate
that's my excuse
also I got a gamepad how stupid is this
I'm a keyboard man but you know on these
platforms especially like Super Meat Boy
they say you need to have you need to
have a gamepad or else if the keyboard
is good for first-person shooters not
for platformers I will give it that okay
get that multiply oh yeah there we go
all right this doesn't seem to actually
be harder I'm wondering but oh damn it
god I can't keep a multiplier up I'm so
stupid
ah I say I'm standing you're going will
do through the easy
watch as I die in the most stupid inane
things oh I'm losing my mind now here's
what you pay to see you guys oh come on
that is you know that's bull that that
was my fault okay that was my fault you
dingleberry you snoozle bakker your
bamboo groom ooh now I did again I did
it again I'm such an idiot
I did it again what is wrong with me
seriously game okay just be patient here
coz there's a big swinging wall of death
and if I know my big swinging balls
which I do everyone knows that
markiplier knows his big swinging balls
is that they're bad for your health but
then again I've never shied away from a
para swing involved wait no nobody Norma
shut up I didn't say anything
you
you guys you guys shut up all so anyway
so just to give some actual gaming
commentary I really like the art style
of this game in in conjunction
conjunction big word there don't know if
I'm allowed to use that word but in
conjunction with the the the really
awesome kind of retro style music it's
actually really really cool and it's a
very smooth experience I got to admit
that uh when I was playing through this
earlier I was cut I was ah come on all
right that was dumb that was dumb of me
I was just saying to myself it even
though you're dying horribly it makes
for a pleasant experience I mean I
didn't I wasn't watching that guy God
okay I can firmly say that it is indeed
getting harder but that's all I can say
about that hopefully I'm just keeping up
enough lives so that I don't have to I
don't have to quit out early because
this game will boot you out if you lose
too many lives which I may or may not do
it's cruel and unforgiving ah balls I
mean I'm in a rush God just take my time
bling bling it but ah there we go take
your time nice and smooth like there we
go
smooth like butter on my bottom hmm
tasty butter tasty bottom butter oh oh
ah you can't beat the stache the stache
is unquestionable look how big swinging
balls of death
I like your skulls and oh it's a fatty
do daddy well how am I supposed to get
on there it fades when the spike goes
down hang on maybe timing whoop ah there
we go oh oh oh yeah there we go alright
dr. multiplier for multiplier increased
hell yeah that must mean it finally
recognized how good I am but hey there
we go
gotcha alright sweet I'm doing great
nope nope no no no no no no get down
give them nah how are my multiplier oh
but it got permanently increased that's
good
oh sweet maybe that means the difficulty
got permanently increased
I'm doing great you guys can't deny but
compared to my other playthroughs of
these type of games I'm doing pretty
good so thank you very much for
believing in me Oh almost walk right
into that laser and I really like the
varied environments okay in if you all
know it was gone it was gone it was gone
haha it was gone I swear I mean I'm very
stressed right now trying to play
perfectly you you try to talk a lot of
people who say that I'm bad at games
what you try to talk and make commentary
about the game you're playing while
trying to play L Pro there's a reason
why MLG oh no oh no I screwed myself ah
okay no perfect score on this one but at
least I won't oh I lost my multiplier
anyway
well they look okay good I lost my
multiplier but yeah there we go
okay all right doing fine doing fine
doing fine
oh it also looks like oh no wait I
didn't know it's still there
okay I thought oh are you trolling
bastard oh you monkey nutter I meet you
oh hey your face ha ha oh come on I
thought of your really this is how it's
gonna be
ah oh no I was doing so good I was doing
so good oh no no no ah come on
hahaha I'm gonna stab someone in the
face preferably with a big swinging ball
okay I just got to stay away from him oh
hi off schnikeys I missed it I missed it
was right there all right whatever
shut up everybody I'm Pro you just don't
realize it
I'm really good at what I do but you
guys are just making me feel bad could
you I can hear your criticisms all the
way from over here through the internet
you know that this is a two-way screen
right I can I can see your reactions as
you're watching this so thank you very
much for all your kind criticisms and
mocking there we go all right here we go
ha there we go okay Oh too rough oh dude
Trump oh yeah all right all right all
right all right there we go
there we go got it get it get it done
got ya
I'm gonna get it took times ten times
ten
cuz I'm that good oh oh look at me go oh
I'm a maniac
Oh sha Wade I'm too busy to answer your
texts right now too busy being awesome
yeah I'm on fire about fire on open ama
now I was on fire god dammit
I had that Wade god damn it Wade you son
of a [ __ ] I was right there Wade and
you [ __ ] it up sorry I apologize for
my leg
god damn it alright whoa huh sorry when
I get when I get going I get going
oh don't know ho ho oh oh oh
dad there we go all right there we go oh
oh by a grad I'll ride out ride all
shoot lasers yeah throw something hard
at me but no don't throw something hard
to me that sounds wrong no oh that those
are big swinging blades of death III
should have realized that they were
gonna be a problem
Oh some pro dodging skills there whoa
can you deny how awesome I am
oh you thought I was gonna be hit by
that flame ninja oh oh how you yield
little faith when is my multiplier gonna
go up again boying
gimme pie me have a bow before Jesus
bountiful oh oh yeah yeah multiplier
increased permanently cuz I'm that
awesome boring boring boring boy yeah
hmm ghost sees ghosts II goose I'm on
level 41 can you deny this is all my
second time playing by the way I've only
played it for a a few minutes before I
started this recording so you act you
cannot deny yeah
ah god I'm doing so good mmm I think I
win the ward you know the high school
word for most improved
yeah that's me Oh Oh what happened I
can't make that jump
that's stupid it didn't oh no no no no
no I was doing so good I was bragging
you can't stop me when I'm bragging no
no ah oh really oh really this is how
it's gonna be gonna be like that no you
sons of [ __ ] I can't go there's
lasers go go go just go just go just go
just go just go yeah yeah yeah
yes yes yes yes yeah there we go all
right oh oh I see you heard me talking
the game heard me talking decided oh no
it was right there
ah-huh I was doing so good
you all saw how good I was doing it oh
man I was like if I was like oh if I was
playing devil my cry would have been
like triple s's all the way across it
would have been amazing whoop up
I missed the bug I missed the bug I I
didn't miss that ball then again I never
miss a pair of balls
wait why no never much shut up shut up
everybody shut up
hmmm anyway back to the commentary on
the game so we're carrying through
awesome
awesome sauce awesome sauce awesome
awesome oh wow this just got quite a bit
harder ok still got it still on no it
didn't go left it was supposed to go
left and it didn't oh man
whew God I'm not watching hang on I just
got to watch very carefully what's going
on here go back aboard go forward go
back oh my god
ah come on go forward go forward go
forward oh no get some kiss kiss kiss
haha okay jump up jump up jump up oh no
they're coming the ball is coming get
down get down get over get up get up
there we go oh this is getting hard guys
that's what she said booing oh no no I
thought it was good no you kicked me off
into oblivion you son of a [ __ ] I
thought for sure those we couldn't get
me ah no no ha that was that was dumb
that was dumb of me
that was very very stupid of me whoop
hey yep well well there we go now we're
on a good rhythm here yeah there we go
ah feels good oh there we go okay so new
hero unlocked level 50 not bad eh not
bad ladies and gentlemen not bad at all
remember I am NOT a profession
but I am pretty awesome I think it did
increase it difficult at Jem I would
have been fine never mind never mind I
think I'm good and in this game just do
enough oh that was way too close okay
just get the gem here we go that was way
too close
Oh ghosty goos hope hope hope oh yeah oh
oh oh yeah
ghosty Gouzenko uh-huh whoa whoa hold on
there for a second hold on
I would prefer the ghosty goos if you
don't mind
oh my god ah fire fire fire fire hot
fire burn my nards
Oh oh no the cloud get him because gonna
get ha ha ha ha ha ha oh ho ho oh ho ho
oh ho okay if you see like seriously if
you want to see like the worst yeah the
worst in the world like the most
horrifying thing you've ever seen in
your life just I'll watch oh no oh no oh
no I've only got four lives left
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no no no I
can't lose it now oh I'm not I'm not
saying let off hudge nutters I'm not
saying I'm like close to the end or
anything but it's uh I'm still you know
I'm kind of happy with how far I've done
so I don't want to lose it
what do I do here okay nothing special
re we got a home man
gah bug get bug get it bug Oh No
ah whatever I just missed it okay
whatever ah oh no got two logs left get
it bug get it bug get big in a bug get a
bug get it oh no fire fire wow the fire
got me damn it oh man but I gotta admit
I'm having a ton of fun playing this
game this game it's really fun
there's my laptop oh I threw oh no I got
one more I thought I'm through wow I
exploded in the fish I think
oh when that was so much fun I got to
admit that game was just pure fun I
would recommend anyone play it it's ten
bucks it's got a ton of replayability
because it is randomized level of them
it's just it's crazy amount of fun hang
on I want to see if I can find now I
probably can't find it I don't know
where Jetman Fat Bob wait I thought I
got to level 25 why didn't I get those
but I got Fat Bob why would I want to
play Fat Bob that seems horrible tiny
Bob maybe but not Fat Bob so anyway this
was a crazy amount of fun I would
recommend it for anyone the story mode
is pretty cool but you know it's
obviously story mode so it goes slow I
don't think the story mode adapts to
your play but it just progressively gets
up usually it progressively gets harder
so give it a try links in the
description it's 10 bucks on Steam a buy
it is definitely worth it I'm gonna be
playing this for a while so thank you
all so much for watching click here
interfaces for more videos and I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
Oh
ah
beep it up better buhdeuce